En este video quiero que nos familiaricemos con
los números negativos y también aprenderemos un
poco cómo sumarlos y restarlos. Cuando los
encontramos por primera vez parecen algo
profundo y misterioso, cuando empezamos a
contar las cosas estamos contando números
positivos. ¿Qué significan un número negativo?
Si pensamos en ello, probablemente encontremos
números negativos en nuestra vida diaria; veremos
algunos ejemplos. La idea general es que un número
negativo es cualquier número menor que 0, y si
eso suena extraño y abstracto pensemos en ello
en un par de contextos diferentes. Si medimos la
temperatura, podríamos medirla en grados Celsius y
Fahrenheit. Supongamos que la estamos midiendo en
grados Celsius. Déjenme dibujar una pequeña escala
en la que podamos medir la temperatura. Digamos
que este es 0° Celsius, este es 1° Celsius,
2° Celsius, 3° Celsius. Ahora digamos que es un
día bastante frío y que estamos a 3° Celsius y
alguien que predice el futuro informa que el día
siguiente la temperatura bajará 4°, entonces ¿qué
tan frío será el día?, ¿cómo puedes representar
esa temperatura? Bueno, si la temperatura sólo
bajará un grado estaríamos a 2°, pero sabemos que
va a bajar 4°; si estuviera 2° más fría estaríamos
a 1°, si la temperatura bajara 3° estaríamos en
0, pero 3 no es suficiente, tenemos que bajar 4°,
de modo que vamos a llegar a 1 más abajo que
0, y al que está por debajo de 0 lo llamamos
-1. Entonces podemos ver en la recta numérica
que a medida que avanzamos hacia la derecha del
0 aumentamos en valores positivos y a medida que
avanzamos hacia la izquierda de la recta numérica
vamos a tener menos -1, -2, -3, y dependiendo de
cómo lo pensemos vamos a tener números negativos
más grandes. Pero quiero dejarlo muy claro: -3 es
menor que -1, con -3 hay menos calor en el aire
que con -1, hace más frío. Aquí la temperatura es
más baja, así que déjenme dejarlo muy claro: -100
es mucho más pequeño que -1, podríamos mirar 100
y podríamos mirar 1 y nuestra reacción instintiva
sería pensar que 100 es un número mucho mayor
que 1, pero cuando lo pensamos -100 significa
que falta algo, si tenemos -100° hay falta de
calor, así que aquí hace mucho menos calor que
si tuviéramos -1. Déjenme dar otro ejemplo.
Digamos que en mi cuenta bancaria hoy tengo
10 dólares -digamos que hoy tengo 10 dólares-,
ahora digamos que salgo, porque me siento bien,
con mis 10 dólares y gasto 30, y para este
argumento digamos que tengo un banco muy flexible,
uno que me permite gastar más dinero del
que tengo, y estos realmente existen, de
modo que gasto 30 dólares. ¿Cómo se verá mi cuenta
bancaria? Déjenme dibujar una recta numérica. Es
posible que ya tengan una respuesta intuitiva. Le
voy a deber algo al banco, algo de dinero. Déjenme
escribir esto aquí. ¿Mañana cuánto tendrá mi
cuenta bancaria? Podríamos decir, inmediatamente,
que si tengo 10 dólares y gasto 30, hay 20 dólares
que salieron de algún lugar, y esos 20 dólares
vinieron del banco, entonces le debo al banco 20
dólares. Para mostrar lo que tengo en mi cuenta
bancaria podría decir que 10 - 30 en realidad es
igual a -20, así que mañana en mi cuenta bancaria
tendré -20 dólares; de modo que si digo que tengo
-20 dólares eso significa que le debo al banco,
no sólo no tengo nada sino que también debo algo.
Lo explicaré de otra forma: aquí tengo algo para
gastar, si tengo 10 dólares en mi banco significa
que el banco me debe 10 dólares, tengo 10 dólares
que puedo usar para gastar. Ahora, de repente
le debo al banco; me fui en la otra dirección.
Si usamos una recta numérica, con suerte esto
tendrá un poco más de sentido. Así que esto es 0,
empiezo con 10 dólares, y si gasto 30 dólares
significa que me moveré 30 espacios hacia la
izquierda, entonces, si me muevo 10 espacios a la
izquierda, si sólo gasto 10 dólares, llegaré al 0;
si gasto otros 10 dólares estaré en -10, si
gasto otros 10 dólares después de eso estaré
en -20. De modo que cada una de estas distancias
representa 10: si gastara 10 dólares estaría en 0,
otros 10 dólares y estaría en -10, otros 10
dólares y estaría en -20, y toda esta distancia
que tenemos aquí representa lo que gasté: gasté
30 dólares. Así que la idea general es que cuando
gastas o si restas o si baja la temperatura, nos
movemos a la izquierda de la recta numérica, los
números se volverán más pequeños, y ahora sabemos
que pueden ser menores que 0, pueden ser -1, -2,
incluso pueden ser -1.5, -1.6; te vas cada vez más
hacia la izquierda cuanto más pierdes. Si sumamos,
si recibo mi cheque de pago, me moveré a
la derecha de la recta numérica. Ahora,
considerando esto, vamos a resolver un par de
problemas de matemática pura. Pensemos en lo que
significan 3 - 4. Una vez más esta es exactamente
la situación que hicimos aquí con la temperatura:
empezamos en 3 y restamos 4, entonces vamos a
movernos 4 a la izquierda, vamos 1, 2, 3, 4,
eso nos lleva a -1, y cuando empezamos a hacer
esto realmente comprendemos lo que significa un
número negativo. Los invito a visualizarlo
en la recta numérica y avanzar dependiendo
si están sumando o restando. Ahora hagamos un
par de ejemplos más. Digamos que tenemos 2 - 8,
y pensaremos en más formas de hacer esto en videos
futuros, pero ahora sólo usemos la recta numérica.
Tenemos el 0 aquí y estamos en 1, 2, si vamos
a restar 8 eso significa que vamos a movernos
8 hacia la izquierda, así que vamos a ir 1 a
la izquierda, 2 a la izquierda, hemos ido 2 a
la izquierda para llegar a 0. ¿Cuántos más nos
tenemos que mover hacia la izquierda? Bueno,
ya hemos avanzado 2 a la izquierda, para que sean
8 tenemos que movernos 6 más hacia la izquierda,
entonces vamos a tener que mover 1, 2, 3, 4, 5,
6 más a la izquierda. ¿A dónde llegamos? Bueno,
estábamos en 0, esto es -1, -2, -3, -4,
-5, -6, entonces 2 - 8 = -6, 2 - 2 sería
0. Cuando estamos restando 8 necesitamos
restar otros 6, así que llegaríamos a -6,
6 por debajo de 0. Déjenme hacer un ejemplo
más, y este será un poco menos convencional
pero espero que tenga sentido. Digamos que tenemos
-4 - 2, entonces comenzamos con un número negativo
y luego a eso le restamos algo. Y si esto les
parece confuso, recuerden la recta numérica.
Así que aquí tenemos 0, esto es -1, -2, -3, -4,
aquí es donde comenzamos. Ahora, a -4 le vamos
a restar 2, de modo que vamos a movernos 2 a
la izquierda, si restamos 1 estaremos en -5,
si restamos otro estaremos en -6, estaremos en
-6, esto es -6. Hagamos otra cosa interesante,
empecemos en -3. Digamos que tenemos -3 y en
lugar de restarle algo vamos a sumar 2, entonces,
¿a dónde llegaríamos en la recta numérica?
Comenzamos con -3 y sumemos 2, así que vamos
a movernos hacia la derecha, entonces sumamos 1
y llegamos a -2, pero tenemos que sumar otro 1,
llegamos a -1, nos movemos 2 a la derecha,
entonces -3 + 2 = -1. Y pueden verlo ustedes
mismos, pero todo esto se ajusta a nuestra noción
tradicional de sumar y restar. Si comenzamos en
-1 y restamos 2, deberíamos obtener un 3 negativo,
es como ir al revés de lo que hicimos aquí arriba:
-3 + 2 nos lleva a -1, entonces si comenzamos
en -1 y restamos 2 deberíamos volver a -3,
y vemos que eso sucede, si comenzamos en -1, justo
aquí, y restamos 2 nos movemos 2 a la izquierda,
volvemos a -3. Con suerte esto comienza a
darles un sentido de lo que significa trabajar
con números negativos o sumar y restar números
negativos, pero vamos a hacer muchos ejemplos
más en el siguiente video y, de hecho, vamos
a ver qué significa restar un número negativo.